uh another guy who was just absolutely
terrible during covet this is just a
quick throwaway for you a tweet from the
New York Post uh let's do it again New
York's push for probe of Cuomo's five
million dollar covid-19 book deal you
may remember that at the height of kovid
when everyone was saying you know Andrew
Cuomo he's going to be Joe Biden's
attorney general and he's the hero of
kovid and everything else he ended up
resigning in disgrace killed a lot of
old people by sending them back into
nursing homes and everything he wrote
right he wrote air quotes a book on
covid leadership I think at this point I
want people to have the information to
protect themselves got it uh everyone is
worried about their family get the facts
inform yourself and that's what I'm
trying to get done thank you Governor
thank you very much the name of the book
is American crisis it's on sale today
whether wherever you like to buy your
books got a 5 million dollar advance
that's what I'm talking about the
laundering of the lies right you keep
doing it everything wrong and you'll be
rewarded handsomely for it well now
they're looking into it and he may have
to give that five million dollars back
ironically if he was if he was the
governor right now of New York it'd
probably be a little bit better than
hochul but uh hey you get what you vote
for